バンカラジオバ俺の名前はや最近はマイ
クラフトにはまってる俺もマイクラの世界
に入って建築とかしてみたいな屋根ちゃん
あんた宿題したのけこいつは最強の母親け
けけけかにし
た行け行け行け行け行け行け行け行け
うるさいな集中させろよ行け行け行け行け
お
ああ
あ
うわどこだ
ここもしかし
てマイクラの世界
[拍手]
[音楽]
木材
ゲットでき
た見つけ
たおおやおや
おや
[音楽]
よし今日はこのぐらいにしとくかう
やばいマイクラの世界は夜になると
モンスターが発生するん
だ
[音楽]
くえこりゃまずい
ぞくえ
なかっ
[音楽]
た熱
あ熱い熱いよ
熱いうわ誰だ
よは何言ってんだ
[音楽]
出き
た現実世界に帰る方法を教えるね方法は
ただ1つエンダードラゴンという
モンスターを倒すことだエンダードラゴン
がいる場所に行くためには様々なアイテム
が必要になる現実世界に帰るにはエンダー
ドラゴンを倒せばいいってことだなうん
そのためには強い装備と生活するための家
が必要だ行く
[音楽]
ぞここは村村人はいろんなアイテムを持っ
ていて交換してくれるん
[音楽]
だ木材しかないけどやって
みようこちらの木材ただの木材じゃあり
ませんよ少しで加えてあげれ
ば松明になっ
たりツルハになっ
たり弓もなっちゃいますこの魔法の木材
近年の環境より非常に数が少なくなって
おります手に入れるなら今ですよはいぞぞ
ありがと
はいここの村頭が悪すぎてちょろい
[音楽]
ぜもっと効率のいいマイニングの仕方ない
のかなそう
[拍手]
[音楽]
だこれでマイニングも楽勝
だう
あ
足ついに拠点の完成
[音楽]
だスティーブ急にどうした助けて
ああクリーパーだう待て待てストップ
ストップストッ待て
待て
あまた1から作り直し
だあれがエンダー
マンエンドに行くにはあいつがドロップ
するエンダーパールが必要に
なるくらえ
何
ああ
くそくそ全然攻撃が当たら
ないもう終わり
[拍手]
なあいつ水弱いんだな
ほらこっち
だほらかかって来い
よエンダーパールゲットだ
ぜできたゾンビトランプだ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ただゲを振ってるだけで経験値爆発的だ
ねこれを使ってを
[音楽]
見つけるここ
かこれがエンド
要塞スティーブやっぱり俺現実世界に帰り
たくないよ今日のためにたくさん準備した
んだろ僕たちはまたどこからで会えるよ
[拍手]
これ友情の印
だそれじゃ行って
[音楽]
くれ
あかかって
こいえ
でるお母さん姉ちゃんあんたいつまで
ゲームの世界にいるの最強装備の今の俺が
お母さんに負けなせなんか
ない
[拍手]
おりどうだ
ああこ攻撃が効かないだっ
てダイヤの防が一瞬で壊れる攻撃に
アもうおしまい
なす周りにあるハゲ脱を壊すんだ現脱を
壊せばエンダーキーコの自然回復は
止まるなるほど
行くぞ
[拍手]
セブ
おりラスト1個
だ
うわああ
やった勝ったつのを倒したぞ
よっしゃおい待てどうなってんだ
やめろあれようやく目が覚めたのねあんた
が無視し続けるからめに骨を見舞したのに
[音楽]
おそしたらあんた気絶しちゃってさすがに
やりすぎたって反省した
わってことは全部夢だったのかさ目が覚め
たってことで宿題しなさいいやこってち
なさい
[音楽]
登録者100万人突破に向けて生配信を
行います生配信は99万5000人あたり
から始めたいと思うのでみんな見てねこの
動画は次の動画のヒント
[音楽]
よちゃちゃチャンネル登録チャンネル登録
チャンネル登録よろしくチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
最初はグじゃんけん登録またねチャンネル
登録